Alter das sind wirklich Geisteskranke
Apple Retouren alter Schwede guckt euch
das mal an
sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen von uns
sind das bitte viele davon haben
natürlich irgendeinen Defekt aber das
sieht schon heftig aus ihr seht selbst
jede Menge iPhones
smartwatches
[Musik]
boah die hat bestimmt einen Gesamtwert
von keine Ahnung auf jeden Fall über
50.000 € die haben ja auch
verschiedenste Schäden der zum Beispiel
Pixelfehler was hat der der ja gut also
viele davon sind halt irgendwie
beschädigt aber trotzdem heftig immer
diese Leute auf tiktok sie glauben die
Geschichte ist wahr wie viel bekommst du
für diese Werbung und eine Rolex ein
Aktienpaket und die Mona Lisa alles hier
drin naja dummheit tut weh